nous sommes parmi vous presque invisible
mais prêt à donner notre vie pour lutter
contre le terrorisme et le grand
banditisme on descendre en piéton basket
et blouson de cuir un simple calibre à
la ceinture
ou cagoule noir arme de
précision gilet par bal et casqueelourd
c'est bon pour tout le monde les gars
nous intervenons dans les situations
extrêmes quand il n'y a plus d'autres
recours quand il n'y a plus d'autres
rempart contre le
CH les autres services de police
parisien nous appellent également à
l'aide pour clôturer leurs enquêtes les
plus
délicates traer les criminels les plus
[Musique]
redoutables nous sommes la brigade de
recherche et d'intervention de Paris
celle qu'on appelait l'antigang du temps
du commissaire Broussard et de Jacques
messerine et que vous connaissez
aujourd'hui sous ce logo
[Musique]
mythique
je suis contacté par
des services locaux une bac du 94 à
Valenton qui a découvert un véhicule
dissimulé dans un parking privé c'est
une Mégane RS type
3 il a été volé sur une une commune dans
le
91 dans un garage souterrain elle
supporte des des fausses plaques qui
sont riftées dessus qui correspondent
pas au modèle
ben le parking est vide mon avz l'
enlevé donc on commence à tourner sur le
secteur et on repère plus le véhicule il
est caché on la découvre
pas al ce véhicule a la particularité
d'être une petite voiture puissante très
mobile et qui permet généralement de
fuir les services de police assez
rapidement donc ce genre de véhicule est
typiquement ce qu'on appelle nous un
véhicule de
guerre c'est une typologie de véhicule
dont on sait qu'il va être utilisé pour
faire des opération soit trafic de
stupéfiant soit des attaques donc c'est
un véhicule très intéressant on sait
qu'il faut investir tout de suite sur ce
renseignement travailler et identifier
quels seront les utilisateurs quels
seront les groupes criminels derrière ce
véhicule on est on est sur zone là et je
vais me positionner là-bas je vais
m'enterrer bien
[Musique]
on connaît très bien le le secteur il y
a un grand nombre de délinquant assez
connus voire même du banditisme et
peut-être même du grand banditisme qui
ont les épaules quoi pour organiser ces
véhicule de guerre je vais traîner un
peu jusqu'à 6h du match je pense je vais
voir ce qui se passe j'ai peut-être un
défaut c'est que j'ai une une
imagination un peu grande ce véhicule
j'imagine qu'elle va servir à commettre
un
délit type homejcking carjcking
braquage vol de vol à main armé dans une
supérette des choses comme
ça il y a pas de voiture il y a rien
c'est mort là ouais
ah on est sur zone là et et là je vois
que les rues sont assez
calmes il faut savoir que ces cités
elles vivent toute la nuit toute la nuit
il y a du mouvement il y a du va et
vient il y a des superettes qui ont
rideau fermé mais de derrière ça bouge
ça trafique ça ça boit l'alcool ça fume
de partout il y a un va et vien continue
et là ce soirl zéro pas un mouvement
notre première crainte quand on ne
retrouve pas la voiture c'est qu'on
pense qu'ils l'ont fait disparaître donc
faire disparaître c'est la brûler ou la
noyer c'est pas le
[Musique]
cas
c'est quoi
ça tu
[Musique]
dorstoi
blanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus tard on apprend que par
notre étatmajor qu' qu'un distributeur
de billet a explosé à sa des fausé et on
se dirige rapidement sur
place
j'arrive et là je vois des détritus par
terre et des caissettes de billets donc
qui sont éventrés on a des billets au
sol qui sont partiellement déchirés et
qui ont des traces de de brûlure des
véhicules qui étaient stationnés à plus
de 10 m ont des impacts sur les
portières ont des vitres des vitres
impactées
[Musique]
aussi un domicile avait reçu dans le
portail et dans le muret une une porte
blindée qui sert la fermeture du DAB la
porte blindée arrive de l'autre côté de
la rue détruit le mur d'un propriétaire
imaginez une personne qui traverse la
rue au même moment et bien elle n'est
plus de ce monde aujourd'hui la porte
s'est arrêtée à 2 m du de la
fenêtre derrière laquelle dormait un
nouveaué et si la porte continue un peu
son son chemin alors bien sûr avec des
silles on peut refaire le monde mais les
blessures occasionnées sur sur un enfant
aurait pu être très
[Musique]
grave alors pour attaquer les
distributeurs il y a tout types de
moyens vous avez des des moyens
mécaniques ça va de la du tract
PEL la voiture
bélier
on a vu aussi des attaques faites à la
hache et la
disqueuse sur un modèle beaucoup plus
puissant et beaucoup plus fort bien sûr
les attaqu à
l'explosif dans l'imaginaire des des
délinquants c'est juste en dessous de
l'attaque de fourgon l'attaque de
fourgon c'est un peu le myth c'est c'est
h voilà juste en dessous il y a
l'attaque de dab beaucoup de
distributeurs de billets subissent ce
genre de d'attaque à
l'étranger en Allemagne en Suisse il y
en a plus de 400 sur les deux pays en en
l'espace de 2 ans avec des grosses
équipes
mais cette infraction n'a pas eu lieu en
petite couronne et dans Paris intramuros
sur le secteur depuis 2015-26 l'attaque
de dab avec de l'explo c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas vraiment fréquent
parce que ça suppose une maîtrise de
substances qui sont quand même
extrêmement dangereuses donc il y a peu
d'équipes qui sont capables de maîtriser
ce genre d'attaque bah le mode
opératoire on le connaît c'est ils
remplissent de gaz ils font exploser
avec une mèche un détonateur ou alors la
création d'une
[Musique]
étincelle il faut bien connaître les les
quantités de gaz nécessaires pour faire
voler en éclat l'objectif sans trop
fracasser l'intérieur puisque on va
avoir la perte de la cargaison quoi donc
on a des gens forcément des de daable
qui ont un passé de délinquant qui est
réel qui ont du courage de la témérité
ou de la folie qui leur permet de se
mettre en danger à ce pointl pour
récupérer cet argent donc on sait qu'on
a à faire une équipe déterminée
expérimentée dangereuse
les attaques de dab au gaz explosif qui
n'ont pas fonctionné viennent souvent
d'un manque de
connaissance j'ai une petite anecdote
qui concerne des
bandits les malfaiteurs décident
d'attaquer l'arrière d'une poste et ça
se trouve dans une petite cour
fermée donc les deux individus sautent
le
mur rentre mett la charge sur le
DAB
allume et à ce momentlà ils
s'aperçoivent que la Cour est toute
petite et ils arrivent pas à remonter
sur le mur et
là l'explosion se produit les deux
individus sont blastés ils perdent
conscience et on vient les
récupérer dans le cadre de l'attaque de
sa mort défoncé là la méthodologie les
connaissances le savoir-faire tout ça
doit être réuni donc forcément et bien
ils font partie du haut du spectre du
[Musique]
banditisme
nous sommes immédiatement interpellés
par un locataire d'un des étages et il a
filmé une partie de la scène pas
l'explosion mais après l'explosion il a
réussi à prendre avec son téléphone une
partie de la scène et qui nous permet
d'identifier clairement notre Méans
blanche et de voir plusieurs formes
d'individus safférer autour du
distributeur de
billet ma première réaction est un petit
peu contrastée parce que j'ai une
certaine satisfaction de dire bon on a
on a le bon véhicule on a une belle
équipe et en même temps ils sont dans la
nature on galère à retrouver la voiture
il va falloir qu'on bosse et qu'on les
retrouve j'ai une certitude c'est que à
la fin les les les bons gagnent donc ça
prend parfois un peu de temps ça se
passe jamais comme prévu et ça c'est
tout le sel du métier de la bie he c'est
les délinquants nous surprennent
toujours ils se surprennent eux-même ils
sont imprévisibles mais à la fin on
finit par les arrêter moi je suis un peu
Friant de ce genre de d'individu parce
que c'est on est là pour ça en fait
notre service est là pour traiter la
grande délinquance et le banditisme
violent on sait répondre à ça on a
l'armement pour la formation pour
l'équipement pour les physiques qui sont
adaptés aussi les sports de combat pour
certains les les méthodes de travail on
a on a tout ce qu'il faut pour répondre
à ce genre d'individu donc quand on a un
groupe de ce genre la motivation vient
toute seule il y a pas de
[Musique]
souci on trouve clairement des qui ont
été apportés par les individus pour pour
commettre leur méfet ces éléments c'est
du scotch et des un système de mise à
feu c'està-dire l'appareil qui sert à
créer l'étincelle au
sol dans l'heure qui suit leseffet avec
un collègue on retrouve le véhicule ils
l'ont rangé ils l'ont recaché et on la
retrouve elle est propre elle est bien
garée elle n'a pas de trace l'intérieur
est propre
elle est toujours verrouillée est prête
à repartir ouais c'est bon j'ai retrouvé
la MAN c'est sûr que c'est cellel et
donc ça nous permet de penser que le le
véhicule est pas grillé comme on dit en
terme il est pas grillé de toute façon
s'il était grillé il aura été il aur
fait un barbecue terminé donc pour nous
ça va remonter à la connerie donc c'est
plutôt très positif car on pense qu'ils
ont confiance en leur véhicules de
guerre
et ils ont des d'autres projets la
question qui se pose en fait c'est que
fait-on de ce coup d'avant ce qu'on a
sur
eux dans la matinée qui suit les faits
une juge d'instruction se saisit du
dossier et elle décide immédiatement de
nous csaisir avec la berlé la brigade de
répression du banditisme de
Paris la prestigieuse BRB c'est un
élément très motivant parce que depuis
des décennies aucune
cisine n'a été faite entre ces deux
services parce qu'on on est souvent sur
sur le les mêmes bandits mais on
travaille pas de la même
[Musique]
manière on fait une espèce de réunion un
brainstorming entre toutes les têtes
pensantes des deux services soit on
décide d'aller tout de suite au résultat
et de faire de l'ADN enlever le véhicule
de faire de l'ADN et on se dit qu'on va
accrocher les gens avec l'AD mais on
n'ayant plus de véhicule de guerre àors
dispo notre équipe va certainement
modifier ses ses projets soit on se dit
on
va prendre sur nous de laisser ce
véhicule vivre pour voir déjà s'il y a
d'autres personnes qui l'empruntent
quels sont les individus qui
l'empruntent voir si ça peut nous amener
sur un flag et cetera la
BR c'est le flag parce que le flag en
délit judiciaairement ça paye comme on
dit c'est-à-dire que les gens sont plus
lourdement condamné donc en fait c'est
ce dilemme dans lequel on se trouve avec
avec nos camarades de la BRB et on va
prendre une voix plutôt que
l'Autrec conduise bien le choix est fait
de de faire vivre le de laisser vivre le
véhicule de guerre et de de le
surveiller euh
constamment
c'est un choix tactique moi à titre
personnel qui me qui me satisfait mais
on sait qu'on va faire énormément de
sacrific sur notre temps professionnel
et privé surtout notre temps
privé et on va manger des heures quoi
comme on dit on va manger des heures de
nuit des heures la
journée les weekends ça accré le seeur
il y
19h49 reçu à gâcher hacher et martyriser
notre vie sociale personnelle et
privée dis-moi demain tu finis à quelle
heure
12h25 d'accord parce qu'il y a le
dentiste de ta sœur à 13h20 là donc euh
tu sortiras vite je je récupérerai McDo
je pense et on mettra ta sœur chez le
dentiste après je te je te laisse poulet
je vais briffer les collègues 21h tu es
là rassure non non
22h 23 22 22 ou 23 ouais à tout à
l'heure
tout j'ai un emploi du temps haché et
très curieux qui correspond à aucun
emploi du temps vous dormez je pars vous
vous allez au travail moi je rentre
dormir 2h je repars à midi enfin bon
allô ça va comment s'est passé ta
journée de rentrée pas bien parce que
demain j'ai dentiste oui mais on va y
aller en em tranquillement t'inquiète
moi je dis-moi tout attends raconte-moi
ta journée
jeupé tu es quoi occupé ah bah dis
donc depuis 2007 je suis dans des
services un peu
spécialisés je je fais subir ça ma
famille et donc très délicat ouais
[Musique]
ouais 2 derrière en attente et dans le
l'état d'esprit de faire un flag donc si
ça remonte le projet c'est de les
interpoller sur le le prochain
fait nous on fait d'abord des
recroupements ouais oui c'est probable
par rapport au aux individus qui sont
dans le secteur moi je reste là-dessus
ouais ouais et on a rapidement une
dizaine une quinzaine de noms qui
peuvent être amenés à utiliser ce genre
de véhicule c'est l'essence même du
travail de la BRI on part avec très peu
d'éléments et on travaille jusqu'à
identifier l'activité criminelle les
individus et les interpellés on met le
le cran sur potentielle interpellation
d'individu dangereux armé comme étant
des des crimes avec de l'explosif
beaucoup d'entre eux sont connus pour
des détentions d'armes pour des vols
avec armes et dans les armes ce sont des
armes de point c'est pas que des
couteaux des armes
[Musique]
blanches donc on met tous les moyens
nécessaires et on est nombreux équipés
en véhicule en armes et tous les modes
surveillance de ces nuits qui suivent
sont en mode interpellation et et
sautent dessus comme on dit
[Musique]
véhicule fait un saut de puce une nuit
très
rapide pour changer de cité de
secteur c'est la voiture vient de
partir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
DESC
je va attendre qu'il me
dépasse temporis on se jette pas dessus
ouais c'est bien
reçu il pris à droite puis après il a
continu tout droit mais il roule
vraiment comme
une et là il passe dans une cité très
connue où on a une majorité de nos
suspects qui vivent alors attends on va
faire les anciens
rien de se jeter dans la gueule du loup
des bandits un peu chevronnés du
94 attendre s'il traîne pas trop il
repart je le verrais passer
là pour l'un d'entre eux des lincant
chevronné un blouson doudou noir
brillant ultra connu stupéfiant vol
Larin vol de voiture refus d'tempéré le
délinquant classique d'une cité
classique
sont
curiux ils ont déplacé le véhicule de
guerre on les a vu suivi identifié au
bout de 4 jours on commence à avir
clairement un caneva d'individus P pant
être les utilisateurs et les les acteurs
de ce distributeur à
[Musique]
l'explosif véhic est revenu au point de
départ
donc où on était cette
nuit et puis là-bas pour planquer
c'est la
misère mais on passe des heures dans
cette caisse c'est infernal c'est
clairement des cités difficiles avec du
du bandit du délinquant qui sont des des
zones où la la police travaille et peut
se rendre mais qui sont à la main de ces
délinquants quoi les caves les boxes les
par ing sont sous leur contrôle les
véhicules sont connus sont des
cités en tenoir et qui qui sont en
impasse pour l'une d'elle donc si vous
passez une fois on vous a eu deux fois
on vous reconnaît donc c'est pas des
lieux faciles à exploiter pour des
surveillances
policières
donc au bout du 6e jour pour les les
têtes pensantes les directeur
d'enquête la stratégie est peut-être
qu'on va perdre le véhicule s'il se met
à le cramer si s'il détecte la
surveillance immédiatement le véhicule
peut brûler et brûler B des perditions
de preuve des perditions de de trac
génétique la décision est prise avec
avec madame la juge
d'instruction de faire enlever le
véhicule 7è jour pour préserver ces trac
le faire faire un enlèvement discret
pour nous qui aimons le terrain on
préfère faire le flag on aime ça c'est
ce qui nous motive après on se rend
compte que bah c'est pas tout le temps
facile à faire et queon est un petit peu
tributaire de des
décisions du juge donc on applique tout
simplement sa
décision
donc le véhicule est récupéré est
isolé et tous les prélèvements trace ADN
papillaire et tout ce qui peut
intéresser l'enquête et qui se trouve à
l'intérieur du véhicule et saisiss les
et envoyé au
[Musique]
labo on a deux noms qui ressortent et
qui sont où l'ADN trouvé dans le
véhicule ainsi que sur des pièces
importantes notamment ce qui a permis de
créer
l'étincelle provoquant l'explosion sur
les lieux de de l'infraction et ça
correspond aux deux personnes à deux des
personnes qu'on avait isolé suivi et
remarqué sur nos surveillances ce sont
des délinquants connus hein puisqu'on
les identifie avec un ADN parce qu'ils
sont fichés par les services de police
parce que ce sont déjà des délinquants
d'habitude et ça confirme laadn de de
notre
ami on commence vraiment à isoler cet
individu comme une des têtes pensantes
de la bande organisée donc là on a une
première partie de l'équipe un premier
embryon sur lequel on va pouvoir
travailler sur leurs habitudes leur
contact leurs moyens de communication
leur
déplacement faut souligner les les
investigations de la BRB qui sont
énormes massives ouais ça va rou ouais
euh il branche jusqu'à 27 ou 28 lignes
dans des téléphones de guerre donc un
téléphone de guerre c'est celui qui sert
à à se déplacer sur les lieux à se
contacter entre malfaiteurs et à
participer au vol à participer au fait
et qui sont éteints en journée
généralement et qui sont allumés que
pour les moments
clés donc ce travail de téléphonie est
primordial car on tu reçu le colis ou
pas
on isole les individus on confirme
l'utilisateur du téléphone on confirme
la présence de cet individu sur les
lieux du vol de la voiture et sur le
déplacement pour aller au Daam et sur le
retour du Daam donc on a clairement x
éléments grâce à la téléphonie qui te
fournissent des preuves la semainnière
sur la téléphonie on se rend compte
aussi que ils sont intéressés pour
refaire un fait très rapidement ils ont
cerné une sur sa des fausé nous on
identifie deux distributeurs de billets
qui sont immédiatement mis sous
surveillance les sont pris c'est correct
ouais écoute on est éclaté dans dans le
secteur
ou c'est on pense que c'est celui-là le
plus intéressant ça va être
celuilà
on est là on guettete on attend on est
plutôt confiant on sait que ça va
prendre un peu de temps mais voilà cette
capacité de durere c'est c'est aussi une
des forces de la baerie
je viens de croiser un véhicule gris
deux fois sappelle monospace
gris BT et en qui est qui est jusqu'à
avenue Anatole France donc pas du tout
dans notre
secteur on a clairement isolé dans des
conversations et dans des surveillances
qu'ils n'ont pas de véhicule de guerre
et ils sont même en mal d'un véhicule de
guerre et ils regrettent même la Mégane
sur certaines écoutes il est rare qu'un
criminel ne réitère pas ils ont trouvé
une première voiture de guerre ils vont
retrouver d'autres ils vont se
reconfigurer ils vont retrouver un
véhicule ils vont retrouver des
moyens on va être surpris et euh un
petit peu
un petit peu contrarié pour ma part car
notre
équipe 4h du matin prend des poubelles
de la commune de
Valenton charge les bonbonnes de gaz
dans les pou sur les
poubelles et se dirige vers le CIC de
Valenton qui est au milieu des deux
[Musique]
cités la deuxième attaque elle prend
tout le monde de cours et donc donc là
ils font exploser ce
[Musique]
distributeur moi je reçois un coup de
fil et chef de groupe me dit ils ont
tapé en bas de chez eux quoi les
cons incroyable
[Musique]
ça c'est c'est improbable c'est quelque
chose qu'un criminel ne fait jamais
et travaille loin de chez lui entre
guillemets mais là ils sont ils sont à
quelques dizaines de mètres de chez eux
et le risque pour la sécurité des des
des des citoyens lambda bah il est pour
les gens de son quartier il est pour sa
mère sa sœur son frère enfin voilà donc
prise de risque improbable qui montre
d'ailleurs une espèce de de de de mépris
pour pour leur propre environnement
voilà c'est
surprenant
[Musique]
on a les faits qui nous sont signalés
immédiatement par nos état-majors donc
on arrive directement sur place à
Valenton on constate les les faits ce
sont les mêmes les mêmes techniques le
même modus opérandise c'est fait avec du
[Musique]
gaz
l'explosion est filmée tout est filmé
par des caméras de
surveillance clairement on identifie
notre objectif
principal qui qui fait des gestes qui a
des éléments physiques et et de
vestimentair qui le
trahissent n'est pas du tout configuré
pour pouvoir intervenir donc peut rien
faire et la précipiter quelque chose
serait absolument contreproductif
surtout voilà dans dans un contexte
aussi dégradé que celui poste explosion
dans un quartier sensible vu le désordre
public que ça crée il est décidé de de
procéder à l'interpellation de tous les
impliqués dans dans le mois qui suit il
y aura pas de de trisè chance pour eux
et pour nous on va dire pas de
possibilité de faire un flag c'est
agaçant on est on est déçu euh voilà on
sait qu'on qu'on a investi que ça se
passe pas comme prévu et voilà on est
frustré on pensait ce soir-là les faire
en flag on s'y préparait et bon bah
voilà on va pas les faire en flagant des
[Musique]
lit
donc ces interpellations qui sont au
nombre de
9 pour se lieux se
prépare 3 semaines à l'avance de 3
semaines à l'avance à l'heure
actuelle notre client il se
trouve chez sanana à Paris
on revérifie les domiciles on recale les
dates je pas la famille de notre am
c'est à ça que je
pense c'est le bon moment il faut le
faire par contre il va falloir le faire
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
quand on aura un alignement des planètes
c'està-dire que tous seront présents et
qu'on pourra faire de grosses
interpellations avec tout le monde ça
paraî pas
mal et donc ça nous met un petit peu en
T
g ou pour moi il est bon aussi lui ouais
parce qu'on se demande si on va pouvoir
à une date bien précise avoir l'ensemble
des impliqués c'est un gros dispositif
neu
objectifs il faut qu'on mobilise nos
ressources conjointes BRB et
BRI aucun des deux services ne peut le
faire tout seul on veut le faire en
sécurité c'est des gens dont pour
certains on pense qu'ils ont des armes
ils ont comme je l'ai dit de lourd
passés
criminel
l'un d'entre eux suite au deuxème fait
dans les semaines qui suivent part au au
Maroc un autre s'en va au Mali une
quinzaine de
jours et un 3è prévoit un voyage en
Thaïlande sur les les écoutes il veut
partir en vacances en
Thaïlande notre objectif c'est d'avoir
tout le monde s'il faut être patient on
le sera et effectivement deux étant
partie on va attendre leur retour pour
déclencher l'opération donc on est sur
sur beaucoup de changements dans leurs
habitudes qui font qu'on on est un petit
peu sur sur des tensions vraiment la
dernière semaine est-ce que celui du
Maroc va rentrer est-ce qu'on fait
l'interpellation malgré son absence
alors que c'est quand même un chaînon
important de de tout tout tout le
mécanisme de de ce de cette bande
organisée c'est un stress pour pour
l'ensemble des des intervenants et des
acteurs de l'enquête
[Musique]
pourquoi on le tape pas la wier c'est
pas wider mec on se démerde on a
téléphone bagnole on va se démerder on
va on va se faire ça tranquillou
ouis avant 2h avant 2h du matin il reste
l'un des objectifs il est très compliqué
parce qu'en fait il ne dort jamais au
même endroit il loge à gauche à droite
dans des hôtels chez des petites amis et
c'est du coup une difficulté pour nous
on sait que le jour J le jour on va
devoir tous les ramasser lui ça va être
compliqué on ne peut pas programmer pour
lui une opération comme pour les autres
donc on va avoir une stratégie qui va
être de procéder à son interpellation en
amont ouais tu attends qu'il se mette en
route lui ou tu veux nous qu'on aille
non on va y aller on va y aller donc
qu'on décide de de faire en sorte de
l'interpeller en dynamique la veille et
ce qui déclenchera le lendemain matin la
vague d'interpellation pour le reste de
l'équipe 1 2 1 2 vous me
recevez casser une porte interpeller
c'est ouais c'est bien reçu c'est pas
c'est pas la même chose que de PIR
interpeller en dynamique sur la voie
publicque justement avec toutes les
difficultés ça rajoute un peu de piment
le fait de euh de le suiv de le
surveiller parce qu'on prend du plaisir
on prend du plaisir c'est beaucoup plus
valorisant justement de rajouter des
difficultés rajouter un peu de piment
55 Ludo notre ami il a bougé là pour
t'informer il vient sur Paris là donc on
se rapproche des marécha et de la Porte
de la Chapelle et Yul il va plutôt sur
dans l'axe avec le
montparnass on anticipe une
interpellation qui va être très complexe
la première condition c'est qu'on veut
qu'il soit seul seul parce qu'on veut
pas que quelqu'un assiste à cette
interpellation et puisse prévenir ses
complices ils sont tout le temps
connectés les uns aux autres sur la
téléphonie via les réseaux sociaux on
doit vraiment s'assurer qu'il qu'il ne
pourra pas rentrer en contact avec les
autres que personne ne verra son
interpellation il faut que ça soit le
fait le mieux possible le plus
discrètement possible ouais Lud ça a
dépassé la porte de CL en cours ça fait
continuité sur P ah ça fait le même
chemin que d'habitude là quand il va à
montparnass en
effet ça risque pas de mettre les
abeilles là si on arrive à le serrer
avant qu' se pr pas au TA il y a pas de
possibilité que le TA son soit en
relation
a la deuxième chose c'est qu'on veut pas
qu'il soit dans un environnement je
dirais où il est connu et où des
passants puissent assister à cette
interpellation et dire qu'il a été
interpellé et ensuite que cette
information remonte au reste du groupe
donc en fait ces deux conditions
cumulatives qui prohibent
l'interpellation rendent en fait le
moment possible d'interpellation très
complexe donc le but est de le prendre
en surveillance en filature surveillance
et de l'interpoller au moment
adéquate il reprend à droite rue salgère
ruegère est dans
mon on laisse on laisse aller on vérifie
euh si le sol dans dans les moments qui
viennent à un moment donné ça serait
intéressant putin j'ai l'impression
qu'il est tout seul moi tu as pris le
coubs comme une balle on se rend compte
qu'il est très compliqué à accrocher
parce qu'il conduit n'importe comment il
est un peu désinvolte dans ce qui est de
la sécurité routière et de la la
conduite dans Paris il prend tous les
risques il prend les couleurs bus il
grille des feux il a pris à droite puis
après il a continué tout droit mais il
roule vraiment comme une
balle donc du coup bah nous c'est c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué de le suivre
si on prend le couleur bus comme lui bah
on va attirer l'œil lui il va se rendre
compte que il y a du monde derrière
lui il a grillé le feu rouge il a avancé
et donc on sait qu' n'hésitera pas à
aller à la percussion des véhicules qui
auront vocation à l'encager pour pour
l'interpeller quelquun qui est dangereux
de manière global dans la vie mais qui
est dangereux en
véhicule
[Musique]
on est amené à se dépasser quand on a
des cibles complexes voilà ça c'est
notre métier on va être là le temps
qu'il faut et oninpellera pas si on n
pas les conditions qui sont totalement
réunies
on était derrière une équipe on avait
depuis quelques temps donc l'équipe en
poogne les éta consommé et donc on se
met un moment en configuration pour les
interpeller mon rôle était de mettre
devant le le véhicule et de bloquer le
le véhicule de la cible ça vient
derrière çaarve de dispo il to
interpelle allez bloqué
blo et au moment où je mets le le pied à
terre la voiture me me fonce
[Musique]
dessus je me souviens juste ma tête Heta
le parebrise je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
l'impression de de me voir mourir quoi
j'ai ça fait ça fait bizarre de se faire
et surtout que je m'y attendais pas quoi
c'est c'est vraiment par surprise je
vois la voiture qui qui arrive sur moi
me percute et après le reste c'est c'est
les copains qui qui me
racontent les choses
quoi
donc je passe sur le capot je rebondis
je je je sais pas par quel miracle la
voiture me roule pas dessus donc je me
relève et là il me repercute une
deuxième fois dans le dos par derrière
donc je rebondis sur le le capot ma tête
vient taper le le parprise je suis
éjecté donc au sol et ça s'est joué à
quelques centimètres pour pas que le
véhicule me roule me roule me roule
dessus
[Musique]
quoi
j'ai eu de la chance parce que ça s'est
limité à un traumatisme cranien avec
perte de connaissance d'une vingtaine de
minutes 15 points de suture et un mois
après j'étais j'étais sur pied mais
c'est plus les traumatismes au niveau du
de la cellule familiale où les enfants
bah ils comprennent pas que on puisse se
faire rouler dessus par par des gens qui
ont commis des des des zneries des
bêtises comme ils disent dans leur dans
leur jargon d'enfants et qui qui roulent
sur un sur un policier quoi ça il ils le
comprennent pas ils le comprennent
toujours pas quoi donc on sait que ils
ont aucune aucune pitié et que si pour
prendre la fuite ils doivent rouler sur
quelqu'un et notamment un policier il le
ils le feront sans sans aucune vergogne
quoi ça leur pose aucun aucun souci
aucun État
d'Able il va arriver à la place du 3K
place du 3
j'arrive sur l'école militaire je vais
essayer de le récupérer on est toujours
très très prudent dans nos dans nos
interpellations
du
milieu arrê
au ils sont combien dedans alors
ou je crois qu'il sont deux je crois
qu'il sont deux il n'est pas seul il est
accompagné d'une femme et continue à
conduire n'importe comment donc on l'
pas en configuration pour pouvoir
l'interpeller ok VO bu il
accélère de
mins sont deux on les sert pas là dans
la
circule donc on le suit pas mal de
temps on est sur rue de Constantine les
gars et ça rentre dans le parking
invalide c'est reçu ah il est devant moi
là il va à la station
essence je fais le choix de le suivre
pour voir son comportement dans la
station s'il met de l'essence il a des
fois on est obligé de s'exposer d'être
au plus près de de la cible et du coup
bah quand on est près de la cible on est
forcément dans dans son cercle et c'est
là qu'on est un peu on va dire on est un
peu plus vulnérable et on le on se
retrouve né àné avec
lui alors il faut rester très calme il
faut justement être s'adapter en fait à
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue et
rester calme et serein il repart je
repars et il a rien découvert il n'a
rien compris il y aura aucun doute à ce
moment-là de la part de l'objectif qu'il
s'agit d'un policier il s'agit
simplement de d'un
automobiliste
il y a 5 niveaux
avec CDO la
plateforme essayons d'aller voir à
l'intérieur là et dès que ça sort on va
on va se mettre au point pour se mettre
en
[Musique]
config il rentre dans une entreprise qui
vend des matériaux pour le BTP c'est
là c'est difficile
de de pouvoir le surveiller et de le
tenir pendant tout ce moment
à première vue ça donne quoi c'est
immense
là il est au deè niveau au niveau des OP
essayez tous de vous rapprocher du
boulevard là pour l'accueillir à la
sortie ah j'ai un démarrage de la
bagnole ça doit descendre là ça va
descendre vers vous je
[Musique]
CIS au moment de la sortie on se rend
compte qu'il est tout seul à ce
moment-là on comprend pas trop à quel
moment il a pu effectivement se
débarrasser de la demoiselle qui
l'accompagnait il y a un chauffeur d'un
utilitaire qui était devant lui qui est
descendu qui a jaé avec lui notre
véhicule cible est précédé par un autre
véhicule complètement
toé on na pas possibilité de voir qui
est dedans ouais il roule vraiment comme
un ou Nissan
nissanan les deux véhicules se séparent
chacun prend sa direction nous on reste
derrière nos véhicules qui n intéresse
ça sort porte d' porte de et ça va en
direction de la station totale il est
tout seul donc on est dans une
configuration on peut l'interpeller on
pense qu'il va mettre de l'essence donc
on commence à s'organiser pour
effectivement essayer d'interpeller à ce
moment-là
[Musique]
allez on me confirme et vous y allez
quand vous
pouvez ce qu'on a prévu c'est que moi je
le contourne et que je le bloque par
l'avant au moment il
repart on est derrière ça va partir ça
va décoller les gars Go et au moment où
on arrive pour l'interpoller coincer la
voiture à l'arrière et à l'avant il
repart aussitôt sans prendre desessens
ça
démarre en fait comme il repart comme
une bombe moi je suis pas en mesure de
le serrer de le bloquer je me dis si je
le bloque et que le mec qui sent la
patate il met un coup de truc il défonce
la voiture donc du coup pour moi on va
pas prendre de risque je me dis c'est
pas grave ça sera pour plus tard non non
c'est passé c'est passé personne na
bloqué devant laissz passer laissez
passer sur le coup j'ai un peu
d'agacement parce qu'on a on a pas été
assez prompte à à bloquer le véhicule
ouais mais ça va il s'est pas inquiété
il arrivé en mode ouf c'était compliqué
de le bloquer là et c'est à ce moment-l
que je vois que
physiquement ça cloche ouis de là pour
moi c'est sur Val là je vois de près on
se regarde dans les yeux comme je te
regarde et puis il me fait ça je lui
fais oh qu'est-ce que tu fais là je je
fais un peu la racaille et puis il se
barre non c'est pas c'est pas notre gars
quoi c'est là que je redemande les gars
la taille du mec
quoi il fait 1 67 ouais de pour moi
c'est sûr que c'est pas lui le mec là
dans la voiture il fait plus d',7
reçu don standby on ninterpelle
pas c'est vraiment le savoir faire de la
BR que de déclencher interpellation au
moment il Douine et de ne
pas s'accrocher sur une décision qui a
été prise et là notre capacité c'est
justement à ne pas rester sur le plan
initial mais à s'adapter donc les
conditions sont finalement pas réunies
ça doit rester fluide la personne ne
doit pas avoir l'impression qu'on a
essayé de
l'interpeller on a un collègue qui suit
le dispo en temps réel pour nous aider
avec les caméras de surveillance de la
ville de Paris donc à ce moment-là je
décide de faire une relecture de cette
scène que j'ai vu qui était un peu qui
était un peu bizarre entre les deux
véhicules il y a ce grand parking dans
lequel il est rentré et à la sortie du
véhicule il est devancé d'un autre
véhicule et si tu veux il y a un homme
qui sort du véhicule de devant qui va au
contact du véhicule qu'on suit et en
faisant la relecture je remarque donc à
bord de ce véhicule là il y a aussi une
femme donc évidemment nous on n pas vu
la scène mais on suppose rapidement
qu'il y a eu un échange de véhicules
fait à l'intérieur du parking
ok donc échange de voiture confirmé si
l'interpellation a lieu sur le la
station service c'est clair que ça
aurait été un peu malencontreux et
surait mis en alerte tout tout le gang
c'est évident on est on n pas assez loin
en fait de de de faire quelque chose qui
aurait été beaucoup moins pro que ce
qu'on a fait ce qui démontre justement
que notre capacité à ne pas nous
précipiter
elle est essentielle pour réussir les
dossiers on a eu un petit coup de chance
c'est très bien on prend la chance aussi
tout façon il faut la chance dans notre
job on va lever on va lever le dispo et
on verra demain après le pétage des
autres ce qu'on fera on mettra une mise
en place sur ces derniers
[Musique]
points
c'est une neuf interpellation c'est des
opérations certes complexes mais qu'on a
l'habitude de
faire c'est jamais une routine euh mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on sait faire on
en fait plus de 200 par an euh donc
c'est quelque chose sur lesquel on est
très pro très
précis
le jourgie se présente et généralement
on fait nuit blanche on dort à peine 1
heure et on a chacun son petit rituel et
puis ces petites habitudes sur des sur
des opérations matinales moi je me
retrouve généralement un peu plus tôt
j'aime bien prendre mon
café ce jour-là on est sur une opération
comme ça on est environ 120 policiers
plus les magistrats qui seront présents
on on a tout
ok le volume de de fonctionnaire
impliqué est très très impressionnant on
va finaliser là le dossier des des 60 on
a une une certaine responsabilité dans
la réussite de de cette journée donc
tous ces éléments font que le stress en
fait le stress sur la fin d'une affaire
comme ça par une interpellation
globale est
présente les 40 vous serez avec le
dembac chez les 60 il y aura médecin et
les chien et puis il y a en précurseur
donc les 20 sur le dernier objectif qui
vont faire peut-être en en civil s'il
bouge ou alors àom en même temps cet
individu qui est le conducteur de la
Méan RS sur sur les de Saint Mor des
fussers part très tôt sur des chantiers
avec son
père c'est voiture classique si ça ouvre
pas en 3 secondes on pète la vitre et
puis on les sort de là donc
attendez-vous un peu de bagarre minimum
et on s'embête pas lesant des voitures
on bar tout de suite et après on se pose
donc allez vous
installer ne partez pas en convoi partez
un par un on est pas en retard j'avais
dit 5h en place il est
moins
ou c'est toi qui nous indiquera le
départ du camion tu confirmes
[Musique]
oui être avec ces hommes par ces moments
là il y a une vraie fraternité c'est
c'est des moments forts on a voilà on a
vraiment ces liens on est tous réveillés
depuis peu de peu de temps il fait noir
autour on est seul dans la ville on est
au cœur de Paris et on va on va
interpeller ces gensl on part en convoi
c'est des moments qui sont qui sont
aussi des moments importants de de la
vie de la brigade parmi tant d'autres
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
on devient chef d'une berie
pi qui arrive en
face prendre en M la sortie du domicile
de laisser quitter les lie avec son
père
à bord du véhicule de leur travail et de
l'interpoller plus
loin hors de vue des cités ave on est
juste devant juste
devant c'est l'interpellation délinquant
dangereux potentiellement armé ou armé
c'est notre métier donc voilà encore une
fois le risque est là mais c'est les
risques pour lesquels on a été créé et
pour lesquels on s'entraîne on laisse
passer le virage on va être hors de la
vue de la sortie de la cité
au fe c'est très bien allez on y
va tu moness tu
monessz de
de il est
interpellé il a pas le temps ni de
prévenir ses
complices ni de réagir à
l'interpellation l'opération est
commencée premier succès il en reste h
et voilà on va on va
continuer avanceer un peu pour la
[Musique]
colonne euh la deuxième séquence se met
en place
silencieusement discrètement dans la
cité malgré le jour qui commence à se
lever le hall numéro
[Musique]
8 il nous reste quelques minutes on est
tous en train de se mettre en place dans
les dans les escaliers des différents
[Musique]
domiciles et choc colonne d'assaut met
en place son infraction et les les top
interpelles sont donnés
ouvertz c'est
[Musique]
parti
police
il y a pas une seconde qui se passe sans
que voilà on est en tête notre sécurité
et la l'heure aussi he c'est pour ça
qu'on a des moyens qui nous permettent
de rentrer très rapidement des domicile
et d'être très efficace neutraliser tout
de suite les gens qui même s'ils
souhaitaent s'ils voulaient être
agressif à notre égard n'auront pas le
temps de l'être les gars c'est sécurisé
je peux faire rentrer les collègues dès
6h4 6h05 6h6 je commence à avoir soit
des messages soit des app et chaque chef
de point en charge du point me rend
compte assez rapidement de la réussite
de l'interpellation sur leur point
notamment les principaux objectifs et
commence alors un petit moment de
relâchement et de de satisfaction quand
vers 6h15 j'ai le dernier appel qui
confirme la présence de frères sur le
dernier point et l'interpellation de
[Musique]
ceci
c'est une belle affaire on en est très
content c'est une affaire je pense qui
qui marquera l'année 2023 parmi beaucoup
d'autres mais c'est une affaire qui qui
est qui est une affaire
réussie cette affaire restera
certainement dans ma
mémoire même si elle elle deviendra
défaillante avec l'âge parce que c'est
quand même un fait notable d'avoir
travaillé sur une AFF faaire dans un
beau dossier avec des
bandits qui font partie maintenant du du
banditisme chevrenné du 94 et et des
environs ça fait partie de des affaires
marquantes de ma
[Musique]
carrière